yeah uh new five pack you just dropped
mm-hmm hey man you've been active Bro
you've been on your [ __ ] man I got to
yeah you gotta turn it up bro
um obviously yesterday was a tough day
one year since we lost golf
it's crazy because I was in Las Vegas
last year when he passed
and uh I was in Las Vegas again this
year and it's like it's crazy how how
are you feeling man A year later
ain't no China
I can't just get over the feeling like
it is what it is it stuck with me but
I'll be all right yeah yeah yeah I'm
glad we're getting an album from Dolph
too because that song that dropped is
crazy my favorite song about was that
song
um one that like because you know
sometimes when people pass like
you know I know Dolph was habitually in
the studio so I know there's not a
shortage of music but that was a record
that you had heard way before like when
you cut it yeah yeah
way way before yeah that's why when I
heard now like the [ __ ] he talking about
in his like
damn bro I always knew it's like Eerie
just just always knew 100 man
do you feel like um because I feel like
golf was somebody who got his flowers
but I feel like
you know he was kind of always like the
underrated like Giant in the game and
and after he passed I feel like it sucks
because the same type of thing happened
with Nipsey where I feel like after
Nipsey died people finally really
appreciated him did you feel like that's
kind of what happened with Dolph where
you saw like
just there was just all of a sudden
everybody was a young dolphin you know
what I'm saying
there's just a normal thing when when
death occurs it's like
I ain't gonna say it's wrong to show
love but you know if it ain't genuine
why do it like if it ain't real like you
know what I'm saying everybody know
like I know like you know
[ __ ] didn't [ __ ] with bro like
that you know what I'm saying and me
either but we always we're gonna be
ourselves no matter what and we gonna
show up and show out and stand out fast
yeah I feel like the paper route way has
always just kind of been like you guys
are very much I mean obviously it's
always been an independent thing but
like
I feel like you guys are are kind of
like outside of like you know people do
the industry [ __ ] they play the industry
games and I feel like dolphin yourself
you guys have always just kind of been
on your own Island and like whoever
wants to come [ __ ] with us we're over
here but we ain't chasing nobody down
type [ __ ] and why Chase it yeah I chase
it 100 man